the universe never fails to surprise
humankind with stunning
incredible facts about its nature
it is literally crowned with mysterious
objects and fascinating phenomena
imagine a star against which the sun
would look like a tiny sparkling speck
in infinite space a star
so large it would be able to absorb most
of the solar system
a celestial object of dimensions whose
values would urge us to question the
feasibility of this star's existence
it has shunned the intrusive gaze of
many a curious observer for many years
and only recently has it revealed some
of its mysteries
cosmo the first in outer space
until a short time ago it was uy scooty
that used to be considered the largest
star known to mankind for a long while
located nine and a half thousand light
years away from the sun
the star is so staggeringly enormous
that it would cover areas beyond
jupiter's orbit
where it placed in the center of the
solar system
its radius may reach 1900 those of the
sun
and its volume may be over 5 billion
times that of the sun
however recently a new giant has claimed
the title of the largest star in the
known universe
it is known as stevenson 2-18
or rsgc 2-18
the star lies approximately 20 000 light
years away from the sun
and is part of the open cluster
stevenson ii although according to some
scientists
this space object should not be
associated with stevenson cluster
as it wouldn't be accurate either way
stevenson 2-18
is located in the scutum constellation
and continues to bear its original name
the star itself was catalogued in the
all-sky database back in the 1990s
but giant clouds of cosmic dust largely
interfered with observation of the star
clusters in the scutum constellation
obscuring them from any observer anxious
to find out more
only in 2020 were scientists able to
acquire data about its size
and the information proved to be
astonishing
according to some estimates the radius
of stevenson 2-18 may reach
up to one and a half billion kilometers
which is 10 times the distance from our
earth to the sun
or 2150 times the radius of the sun
this means that the supergiant's volume
should be about 10 billion times that of
the sun
placed in the center of the solar system
stevenson 2-18 would easily swallow up
saturn
along with all of its rings and moons to
say nothing of the terrestrial planets
interestingly it would take light almost
eight and a half hours to travel the
length of this gigantic stars equator
this is the same time it takes sunlight
to reach pluto
at the remotest point of its orbit
the supergiant's luminosity is estimated
to reach 440
000 times that of the sun although its
surface
is comparatively low at about 3200
kelvin
this is about two times as little as
that of the sun and corresponds to the
red band of the light spectrum
this is the reason why stevenson 2-18
falls into the category of red
supergiants
also this relatively low temperature
implies that most of the star's
radiation is in the visible and thermal
spectra
with amounts of deathly ultraviolet and
x-ray types of radiation
rather negligible in comparison it may
seem strange that in spite of its
impressive dimensions and sufficient
luminosity
stevenson 2-18 cannot be seen from the
earth with the naked eye
but this has to do with its slow surface
temperature as well as clouds of star
dust and gas shrouding the giant star
thus concealing it from observers on our
earth
they absorb and disperse the star's
light and this poses difficulties for
studying
the object the mass of stevenson 2-18
still remains to be gauged
however supposing its inner makeup is
similar to that of uy
scooty and other supergiants it should
be anything within 20 solar masses
if it is the case the average density of
supergiants like that
must be extremely low and almost equal
to the density of the earth's atmosphere
at a height of about 90 kilometers above
the sea level
that is practically on the border with
space
it is really amazing that thermonuclear
energy
that is the kind of energy that gives a
glow to a star is still sustained in
such conditions
supergiant sizes are so mind-boggling
that these objects are hardly steady
most of them are variable in terms of
their luminosity
and as a rule this variability is
unpredictable
no wonder as the overwhelming majority
of supergiants are in the final stages
of their life cycles
which means that they may go supernova
literally at any moment
according to the contemporary scientific
concepts of stellar evolution
it is stars with original masses from 10
to 40 that are the sun that qualify to
become
red supergiants at a later stage of
their existence
thermonuclear reactions in their
interior rapidly burn out all hydrogen
thus turning it into helium after that
fusion reactions of helium
carbon oxygen and lithium become the
chief energy source of the star
life expectancy of stars of this kind is
comparatively short just a few million
years
as it evolves the prospective supergiant
rapidly expands in size and loses its
mass on account of strong solar wind
clouds of stardust and gas surrounding
the original star
are quickly absorbed by the new star
which keeps swelling
way beyond its original size at an
astonishing rate
however its own solar wind creates a new
nebula around the star
on account of the short life span of
this kind of star
no planets can realistically originate
in this nebula
eventually the supergiant explodes
following the supernova or even
hypernova event
the outer layers of the star are hurled
away and then gradually cool off
forming a nebula as for the former core
it becomes either a neutron star or a
black hole depending on its mass
by the way feel free to see our previous
videos about dwarf stars and supernovae
a hypernova event is accompanied by a
high-energy
x-ray burst powerful enough to eliminate
any life within the radius of several
light years
luckily for us and the earth all
supergiants
identified by scientists so far lie
considerably further than that
so we seem to be safe from those due to
active radiation of charged particles
the rotation of stars of this type
gradually slows down
and eventually their outer layers
practically grind to halt
the core of the star meanwhile continues
to rotate quite unabated
and there may be a substantial
difference between the speed of the core
and that of the outer layer taking into
consideration the high luminosity
low temperature and impressive
dimensions on balance
it is safe to assume that the habitable
zone of stevenson 2-18
should be really huge its middle should
lie approximately
663 astronomical units away from the
star's center
in other words 20 times the distance
from the center of the sun to pluto's
orbit
and as for the area of the habitable
zone it is expected to be one billion
times that of the sun
scientists do admit of the possibility
of the existence of planetary systems
around supergiants
but what would these stars short
lifespan and unstable conditions
the chances are almost negligible at any
rate
no confirmed exoplanets have so far been
discovered in the environs of one
stevenson 2-18 lies so far away
that its light travels to our earth for
20 000
years for all we know at this very
moment
its core might be shrinking to form an
extremely dense neutron star
with red hot shards of outer layers
flying away in all directions to become
part of ice skilled space
but mankind will be able to find this
out only in a very distant future
[Music]
you